with nearly six decades of tv series and
films under its belt star track
is a vaunted franchise that always
inspires fan discussion on the best
entries in the series
here's why star trek six the
undiscovered country is the best film
embodiment of the star trek world
creator gene roddenberry imagined star
trek as a wagon train to the stars with
earth settlers boldly exploring the
final frontier of space
but he also conceived of it as a cold
war allegory one in which the united
federation of planets represented nato
the klingon empire stood in for the
soviet union and the romulans were the
red communist chinese
a number of episodes of the original
series allegorized cold war conflicts
including
errand of mercy friday's child elon of
troyeus
the omega glory and balance of terror
producer hart bennett's holy trilogy the
wrath of khan
the search for spock and the voyage home
explored the relationships and trials of
the enterprise crew and the sacrifices
they made for one another
but when paramount brought back wrath of
khan writer director nicholas meyer to
make one
final film with the original series cast
he and leonard nimoy took star trek back
to its cold war roots
imagining the fall of the berlin wall in
space and its aftermath specifically
they wanted to dramatize the hard work
of achieving peace in a world used to
hate
paranoia and xenophobia the film's plot
about a coup
that attempts to derail a galactic peace
conference mirrored the real events
unfolding in the summer of 1991 so
accurately including russian hardliners
trying to restore the old soviet union
that paramount actually tried to rush
the film into theaters before it was
ready
maybe because he started out as a
novelist nicholas meyer has a real gift
with dialogue
sure he borrows some of the dialogue in
his star trek movies from classic works
of western civilization but he's good at
using those works to underscore his
themes
star trek 2 for example opens with spock
giving kirk an
antique copy of dickens a tale of two
cities a novel about sacrifice
later in the film kirk quotes the novel
reflecting on spock's sacrifice for the
greater good
in the undiscovered country meyer has
the klingon character chang lay claim to
shakespeare and even weaves in
references to brave new world sherlock
holmes and peter pan
but meyer also writes excellent original
dialogue the undiscovered country is
about people confronting the prejudice
of their own thinking
and the way in which kirk and spock
acknowledge their own shortcomings and
mistakes is very poignant
they're a great one for logic i'm a
great one for
rushing in where angels fear to tread a
bit later in the film spock asks
is it possible that we too you and i
have become so old and inflexible that
we have
outlived our usefulness it's a very
self-reflective dialogue that allows for
meaningful change
making undiscovered country a film with
exciting character development
a script with plenty of shakespearean
dialogue demands shakespearean actors
and undiscovered country delivers
royal shakespeare company veteran david
warner plays chancellor gorkhan
a klingon ambassador trying to forge
peace with the federation
the great christopher plummer meanwhile
stars as the villainous klingon general
chang who spearheads a conspiracy to
sabotage the peace process
by this time plummer was as famous as a
shakespearean actor on the stage as he
was for his roles on screen
he had made his thespian bones in
canadian theater working with none other
than william shatner
the future captain kirk was plumber's
understudy in wait for it
henry v so when playing chang plummer is
right at home
intending quotes from hamlet henry v
julius caesar
and the merchant of venice while he
taunts kirk and company
to be or not to be that is the question
which preoccupies our people captain
quick
while plummer gives a famously
flamboyant performance as chang he is
fully committed to the role giving it
the dramatic heft it deserves
in fact plummer had been a star trek fan
when the show debuted in the 1960s
despite the fact that industrial light
and magic handled visual effects for
both the star wars and star trek movies
their star wars effects became better
known partly because of star trek's
association with low budget aesthetic in
the original tv show
but the movies featured some impressive
spectacles the space battle inside the
pink clouds of the mutara nebula in
wrath of khan
the enterprise self-destructing and
burning up in the search for spock
and the klingon bird of prey hovering
over a whaling ship in the voyage home
undiscovered country is the most
sustained visual achievement of the
original movie series
it out does those previous films in
several ways as with the mammoth opening
explosion of the klingon mining moon and
the giant purple shockwave that engulfs
sulu's ship the excelsior
there's a terrific action sequence set
on a gravity-disabled klingon flagship
when two masked assassins
gunned down the klingons on board
sending their fuchsia blood floating in
neon globules through the zero-g
environment
star trek vi is also bursting with alien
masks
and makeup putting on a huge prosthetic
show and giving the galaxy
a sense of being diversely populated
finally meyer and cinematographer hero
narita elect for low lighting throughout
which gives the film
a burnished menacing glow every star
trek movie either introduces new
characters or delves deeper into
characters from the original tv series
and the quality of the films often
mirrors how well this is done
take the arch villain khan who made his
classic cinema debut in star trek ii
and contrasts that with spock's
forgettable half-brother cybok
introduced in the wretched star trek 5.
star trek vi
balances out the main cast with a wealth
of memorable new faces beyond chang and
gorkon including gorkhan's fierce
daughter
ozzie bohr played by rosanna desoto as
well as the grandfather of star trek the
next generation's wharf
both played by michael dorn other
sharply drawn characters include a
shape-shifting alien named martia
played by the model iman and kirkwood
smith as the federation president
even christian slater shows up for a
cameo but the best new character is a
pre-sex and the city kim cattrall as
lieutenant valeris
spock's vulcan protege belarus has more
scenes than most of the trek regulars
and the movie
is better for the freshness and vitality
of her character she
and chang along with many other new
characters helped make the star trek
universe feel densely populated
novelizations and other material in the
trek universe had long established the
promotion
to captain of sulu played by george
takei which fans had been clamoring to
see on film for quite some time
his ship the uss excelsior had actually
been introduced in star trek iii the
search for spock
as one of a new generation of starships
that would replace the enterprise
when kirk goes rogue in that movie
starfleet sends the excelsior to
apprehend him but it fails because
scotty has sabotaged the transwarp drive
but fans found the ship cool and they
finally got their wish of seeing sulu in
charge of it when it showed up under his
command
a few films later in undiscovered
country narratively adding another
starship
widens the scope of the film and it
gives one of the primary original
characters something to do besides hang
around on the enterprise bridge
sulu and the excelsior feature
prominently in the dramatic opening of
the film
as well as the exciting climax as they
race at warp 10 to help the enterprise
save the galactic peace conference a
junior officer warns sulu about the
speed to which his commander barks
fly her apart then you can practically
feel takei's relish at getting a line
this exciting after yes siring captain
kirk all those years
sulu's expanded role fits well into the
fast exciting storytelling on display in
the undiscovered country
a sherlock holmes fan writer director
meyer who also wrote the seven percent
solution
infuses a mystery story into the larger
space opera plot as the enterprise crew
races against the clock to figure out
who has framed them for an
act of international terrorism that
jeopardizes a peace conference meyer and
his co-writers leonard nimoy and denny
martin flynn also add a juicy courtroom
trial
an elaborate banquet scene and a prison
escape for good measure
along with all the space battles phaser
fights and philosophical discussions
fans had come to expect
in star trek 2 spock saves the
enterprise and her crew at the expense
of his life
in star trek 3 the enterprise crew
returns the favor but sacrifices the
ship
in star trek 4 the stakes include the
survival of earth and all its people
and by the time we get to the
undiscovered country the fate of the
entire galaxy hangs in the balance
can humans and alien species work
together to preserve the fragile goal of
peace
or is the galaxy doomed to perpetual war
these are the highest stakes of the
series so far
making for great tension the personal
stakes are high in this movie too
whereas the characters had to save each
other individually in previous outings
in undiscovered country they've got to
save themselves as a group
will they be able to see the error of
their ways before it's too late they
certainly try spock admits that it was
quote arrogant presumption on his part
that got them into the story's mess in
the first place as well as his belief in
the inherent superiority of vulcans
kirk meanwhile confesses that he was so
used to fighting klingons it never
occurred to him to believe they might
actually want peace
saying gorkan had to die before i
understood how prejudiced i was
by the end of the film he sees them in a
new light and has even earned their
trust
people can be very frightened of change
inside the starships in the undiscovered
country feel more like tightly packed
ships at sea or even submarines than
through the brightly lit flying living
rooms of the next generation this fits
with gene roddenberry's original vision
of starfleet as a navy with the officers
using nautical directions like port and
starboard and of course the uss
enterprise was meant to be the
descendant
of the many real ship's designated
enterprise including the famous world
war ii aircraft carrier
meyer embraced roddenberry's vision of
star trek as fictional british naval
hero horatio hornblower voyaging in
space
in star trek 6 the director expands that
concept even more fully than he did in
star trek 2
putting the crewmen together in cramped
bunk rooms referring to the kitchen
as the galley and using torpedoes during
warfare
meyer epitomizes the naval theme
beautifully with kirk's great final line
when asked for a course heading he
paraphrases peter pan saying
second star to the right and straight on
till morning of course peter pan was an
adventure set on ships but the line also
suggests the eternal pull of the horizon
which had always informed the hopeful
vision of star trek
it's now expected for popular franchises
to wink at their fans referencing
elements outside of a given film's
particular story but when star trek vi
came out in 1991 the practice was pretty
rare and the film trailblazed in that
area too
at one point when scotty suggests that
their situation is so
dire that they're practically dead spock
quips
i've been dead before meanwhile as the
film tackles the theme of aging it
directly engages the cultural jokes
about the enterprise crew
saving the galaxy in walkers and
wheelchairs but nods to the franchise's
history are never at the expense of the
film's central story
the only responsibility the filmmakers
feel is to make a good final movie
especially after the lackluster star
trek five
the sixth installment grandly sends off
the original cast and crew
but it's also a send-off to the fans who
made it all possible their passion saved
star trek from cancellation and kept it
alive through some pretty weak movies
with star trek 6 the original series
ends on a high note its greatest gift to
fans is saving the best for last
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star trek are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one